as somebody who's fascinated by
military history where do you put
violence
as uh as in terms of the human condition
is it core to being human or is it just
a little uh
tool that we use every once in a while
so i'm going to respond to your question
with a question
what do you see the difference being
between violence
and force let me go farther
i'm not sure that violence
is something that we have to put up with
as human beings forever that we must
resign ourselves to violence
forever but i have a much harder time
seeing us able to abolish force
and i there's going to be some ground
where if those two things are not the
same and i don't know that maybe they
are
where there's certainly some crossover
and the re i think
force you know you're an engineer you'll
understand this better than i but think
about it as a physical law
um if you can't stop something from
moving in a certain direction without
pushing back
in that same direction um i'm not i'm
not sure that you can have a society
or a civilization without the ability to
use a counter force when things are
going
wrong whether it's on an individual
level right
a person attacks another person so you
step in to save that person
um or on uh you know even at the highest
levels of politics or anything else a
counter force to stop the
uh inertia or the impetus of of another
movement so i think
that force is is a simple almost law of
physics
in human interaction especially at the
civilizational level i think
civilization requires a certain amount
of if not violence than force
so um and again they've talked i mean it
goes back into saint augustine all kinds
of christian beliefs about the
the proper use of force and people have
have philosophically tried to decide
between
can you have a sort of an ahinsa uh
buddhist sort of we you know
we would be non-violent toward
everything and exert no force or
or there's a reason to have force in
order to create the space for good
uh i think force is inevitable now
we can talk and and i've not come up to
the conclusion myself
if there is a distinction to be made
between force and violence i mean is
is um is a non-violent force enough or
is
violence when done for the cause of good
a different thing than violence done
either for the cause of evil as you
would say or
simply for random reasons i mean we
humans lack control sometimes we can be
violent
for no apparent reason or goal um and
that's i mean listen
you look at the criminal justice system
alone and the way we
we interact with people who are acting
out in ways that we as a society have
decided
is intolerable can you deal with that
without force and at some level violence
i don't know can you maintain
peacefulness without force i don't know
just to uh be a little bit more specific
about the idea of force
do you put force as general enough
to include force in the space of ideas
so you mentioned buddhism or
religion or just twitter
i can think of no things farther apart
than that okay
is uh the battles we do in the space of
ideas
of um you know the great debates
throughout history
do you put force into that or do you
in this conversation are we trying to
right now keep it to just
physical force in saying that
you you have an intuition that force
might be with us much longer
than violence i think the two bleed
together
so um take
because it's it's always it's always my
go-to example i'm afraid and i'm sure
that the listeners all hate it but but
take
take germany during uh uh the 1920s
early 1930s before the nazis came to
power
uh and they were always involved in some
level of force you know beating up in
the streets or whatever it might be but
think about it more like an intellectual
discussion
until a certain point um
is that it would be difficult i imagine
to keep
the intellectual counterforce of ideas
from at some point degenerating into
something that's more
um coercion um counterforce if we want
to use the phrases we were just talking
about
so i think the two are are intimately
connected i mean
actions follow thought right and at a
certain point
i think especially when when one is not
achieving
the goals that they want to achieve
through peaceful
discussion or argumentation or um trying
to convince the other side
that sometimes the next level of
operations is something a little bit
more physically
uh imposing if that makes sense we go
from the intellectual to the physical
yeah so it too easily spills over into
violence
yes and one leads to the other off
you